in the last video I started introducing
the intuition for the laplacian operator
in the context of the function with this
graph and with the gradient field
pictured below it and here I'd like to
go through the computation involved in
that so the function that I had there
was defined it's a um it's a two
variable function and it's defined as f
of X Y is equal to 3 plus the cosine of
X divided by 2 multiplied by the sine of
Y divided by 2 y divided by 2 and then
the laplacian which we define with this
right-side-up triangle is an operator of
F and it's defined to be the divergence
so kind of this nabla dot times the
gradient which is just nabla of F so two
different things going on it's kind of
like a second derivative and the first
thing we need to do is take the gradient
of F and the way we do that we kind of
imagine expanding this upside down
triangle as a vector full of partial
differential operators partial partial X
and partial partial Y and with the
gradient you just kind of imagine
multiplying that by the function so if
you imagine multiplying that by the
function what it looks like is just a
vector full of partial derivatives
you're taking the partial of F with
respect to X and the partial of F with
respect to Y those are the two different
components of this vector valued
function that is the gradient and in our
specific example when we take the
partial derivative of F with respect to
X what we get so we look over here three
just looks like a constant so nothing
happens cosine of X halves the
derivative of that with respect to X we
kind of take out that 1/2 so 1/2 and the
derivative of cosine is negative sine so
that's negative sine of X over 2 and
sine of Y over 2 well Y just looks like
a constant so sine of Y over 2 is just
some other constant so in our derivative
we we just keep that constant in there
that sine of Y over 2 and
for the second component the partial
derivative of f with respect to y 3
still looks like a constant because it
is a constant now cosine of x over 2
looks like a constant because as far as
Y is concerned X is a constant so cosine
of X is a constant but then the sine of
Y has a derivative of cosine and we also
take out that 1/2 so you take out that
1/2 when you take the derivative of the
inside and then the derivative of the
outside is cosine of whatever was in
there so in this case Y over 2 and we're
multiplying it by that original constant
cosine cosine of X over 2 so still we
have our cosine of x over 2 since it was
a constant times a certain variable
thing x over 2 so that's the gradient
and then the next step here is to take
the divergence of that so with the
divergence we're going to imagine taking
that del operator and dot product in
with this guy so if I scroll down to
give some room here we're going to take
that that vector that's kind of the same
vector the partial partial X and I say
vector but vector ish thing partial
partial Y and now we're going to take
the dot product with this entire guy so
I'll go ahead and just copy it over just
kind of copy it over here and let's see
so we a little bit more room to evaluate
this so here when you imagine taking the
dot product you kind of multiply these
top components together so we're taking
the partial derivative with respect to X
of this whole guy and when you do that
what you get you still have that 1/2 and
then the the derivative of negative sine
of X over 2 so that 1/2 gets pulled out
when you're kind of taking the
derivative of the inside and the
derivative of negative sine is negative
cosine so negative cosine of that stuff
on the inside that x over 2 and of
course we still multiply it by this this
looks like a constant the sine of Y over
2 and we multiply by that sine of Y over
2 and then we add that because it's kind
of like a dot product you add that to
what it looks like when you multiply
these next two components so we're going
to add and you have that one
and then cosine of Y over 2 when we
differentiate that you also pull out the
one-half so again you have that pulled
out 1/2 and the derivative of cosine is
negative sine so now we're taking
negative sine of and then that stuff on
the inside Y over 2 and we continue
multiplying by the constant as far as Y
is concerned cosine of X over 2 is a
constant so we multiply it by that
cosine of X over 2 and then that so that
is the divergence of that gradient field
so the divergence of the gradient of our
original function gives us the laplacian
and in fact we could simplify this
further because both of these terms kind
of look identical but the main point of
this video is kind of how you go through
that process where you you imagine
taking the gradient of your function and
then the divergence of that and that's
what the laplacian is see you next video